today we're gonna talk about a little
thing called it's something that happens
to every woman at least once a month and
let me tell you what guys we're not
making it up it's true it's
scientifically proven and if you've
dated a woman more than a month then
you're probably well aware this is now
during this week ladies don't feel bad
because I know how you feel and guys
don't worry I feel bad for you too
because you have to put up with us
normally I'm the happiest person to lie
but during this week I turn into this
crazy freakin monster I get mad I get
sad I get glad all in the course of five
seconds I'm at the grocery store I'm
happy oh hold on a second wait unset' oh
boy here comes some tears why am i
crying don't know maybe because I can't
have a mac and cheese I'm happy to get
wait a minute now I'm miserable and now
I'm crying it doesn't make any sense why
am i crying the maggots make me sad I
don't know
Justine your food is ready that my
friends is just a little bit off by a
crazy emotion story
I'm gonna go sleep for four days oh just
play call of duty and let out a little
wave I'm not the only one that's like
this right right no I definitely am NOT
because my friends and my sisters we all
deal with it